troubling new signs of the cratering
economy due to the pandemic sales at
retail outlets nationwide plunged more
than 16 percent last month the biggest
decline on record JC Penney became the
latest retail casualty of the pandemic
when it filed for bankruptcy last night
joining the ranks of other major chains
this comes as more and more states are
beginning to reopen in hopes of reviving
the economy at the same time the House
has approved a three trillion dollar
relief package Michael George begins our
coverage from what would ordinarily be a
bustling Soho neighborhood of New York
City Michael good morning Dana good
morning the doors are closed in at some
luxury retailers they're actually
boarded up here in so hope for the ninth
weekend in a row another three million
Americans filed for unemployment last
week bringing the total number of
unemployed to more than 36 million as
much of the country begins the slow
process of reopening the hope is that
like the action at Churchill Downs in
Kentucky the US economy will be off to
the races as retailers in two-thirds of
the states reopened for business
Churchill Downs reopens today those who
love horse racing you're gonna see some
fantastic racing social distancing will
be very distant no fans in the stands
but in hard-hit Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
stores are ready for shoppers John Henny
hopes people stop by his family owned
jewelry business we have disinfectant
and we have ways that we can clean the
jewelry before and after anyone tries it
on in Florida selective businesses like
restaurants and salons are reopening in
New Jersey beaches are open but rides
there are closed and everywhere safety
is the priority but at the buzzards Nest
in Wisconsin bar patrons packed in after
the state Supreme Court overturned the
governor's stay-at-home order it's been
kind of boring sitting in my home
there's only so much we can handle of
each other without having interactions
increased reopening comes after a week
that saw nearly a hundred and fifty
thousand new cases of corona virus in
the US and more than nine thousand
deaths while scientists warned the worst
could still be yet to come Missouri
governor Mike parson is among
politicians trying to strike a balance
I'll just stress this you have to be
able to fight the virus and you have to
be able to open up the economy those two
things have to go hand in hand
federal data estimates 42 percent of
recent layoffs will become permanent
economists say 100,000 small businesses
have already closed for good and many
more are vulnerable at University City
High School in Missouri more than a
hundred parents held a parade for their
graduating kids anything but traditional
but still a celebration it's just like a
small sacrifice that we had to make for
the safety of you know millions of
Americans in Oklahoma the pressure is on
to start football practice talk of these
schools want to bring players back on
June 1st is one of the most ridiculous
things I've ever heard I think if we
bring our players in even one day before
we have to try to start a season I think
it's the wrong thing but a return to
normal will take much longer here in New
York the state hardest hit by the
coronavirus the state's stay at home
order called New York pause has been
extended for at least another month
Michelle a lot for folks to handle
Michael thank you